I reject nation it's Greg Alba here and
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
honest trailers today for the movie elf
starring William Ferrell who has a new
Sherlock Holmes movie coming out will be
the defining one from the guy I'm going
back on movie fights this week I'm very
exhausted there's a lot of stuff I'm
working on right now but I'm gonna
squeeze in movie fast so I'm gonna do my
best and I could use your support going
up against mark n Draco and Clark wolf I
think I am so why don't you go and watch
live 4:00 p.m. screen junkies YouTube
channel it'll be fun and I'm gonna be
angry and annoyed and I'm gonna destroy
my reputation with the amount of heal I
play that day happy holidays Joestar
loves reactions don't forget guys it's
just for you Joe
[Music]
so Christmas movies are sweet some
others are just super super weird we
don't think one of them is all of those
things who's stolen by Santa Master to
find his real sounds like a joke you
might know how I got these tights
showing off is infectious joy I just
like to smile smiling's my favorite
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah interesting
funny pretty delightful funny stuff guys
you guys did it again and I hope that
this Thursday there's some Christmas
related question because if there's one
John uhrin film that I definitely excel
at it is not Christmas movies I've
barely seen them Hey I don't even really
remember the movie a lot of this was
like I forgot about that I would argue
jingle all the way is the best one
because that's weirdly the one I
remember the most amen turbo man you
gotta love it I'm praying that I get a
real challenge and have to cram in as
many Christmas movies as possible the
night of ok there's gonna be one where
it's like you know what's another action
movie that's a perfect Christmas movie
like die hard yeah I have to find the
next die hard or evil weapon it's
perfect see there you go it's not even a
challenge for you no just too good at
this maths while you're on number four
right now fourth movie fight so elf was
interesting experience for me action and
watch it in the theaters because I'm
Jewish
at heart yes is it something about Jim
Carrey turned this down a dude The
Grinch these didn't come out around the
same time right Grinch was like junior
high this was like high school I feel
like yeah I wonder if maybe this was
just a script that was kicking around
for so long the Jim Carrey had time to
look at it maybe it would have got made
with him then he was like mad and then
it probably languished until maybe
welfare would pick girls perfect in this
ya know he really honestly like I think
well I think Jim Carrey could have done
this I I can imagine a version with Jim
Carrey but I feel like Will Ferrell has
the exact right amount of just a certain
kind of energy I feel like Jim Carrey
might have been a bit too prickly it's
like I know he can be sweet
but there's like a zap to what he does
that I think this movie doesn't need so
much I feel like it needs a softer
energy and I feel like even though Will
Ferrell can be very huge huge I don't
know I get a more a cuddly vibe from
Will Ferrell you know it's funny is Jim
Carrey eventually did star with Zooey
Deschanel in the movie yes man I love
them so that worked out pretty well Jim
Carrey Will Ferrell how to work together
quite a bit on SNL as well yeah a lot of
fun facts going around when I first
heard about this movie
Ed Asner had showed me a like photo that
I think his assistant took on camera oh
did I mention I knew ed asner for quite
a long time my dad was like best friends
with the guy ed was like I'm playing
Santa again he's played Santa like 68
times in his career it's cool I was like
oh well Farrell I don't really know him
and it seems like a weird thing at after
Will Ferrell the Cather in a movie that
was my first experience to it and I had
all this excitement and hope and I
didn't even watch it and that's why you
don't talk to it as much anymore that's
why I was just like damn it Greg I
wanted you to come to my movie yeah
there some four - yeah I like a Saturn
now John your big fan of this movie what
do you think it connects so well with
people I think it just has a genuine
quality that a lot of holiday movies
that I see come out you know throughout
the years don't really I feel like a lot
of things try to be very hip and tried
to have like an edge and stuff - you
know appeal wide and bring stuff in but
the thing that's great about seen dr.
Seuss is the Grinch by illumination oh
not yeah you know I'm told to classic
I'm told it might be the goat
it might be the goat of Grinch movies
he's not a goat
he's a Grinch and I think it's just a
really well-made film I mean you've got
a terrific cast of like kind of unlikely
people to bring together it's like you
know you got Will Ferrell in the lead
but you also got James Caan and Ed Asner
and a bunch of other character actors
sure that the kids do love this um
kannan as well but I don't know it just
feels like a real movie that's also a
Christmas movie not somebody going what
can we get out there for Christmas this
feels like an actual story that just is
really dear and it's not cynical at all
and it doesn't like shy away from the
fact that life is real but it's also got
a fantasy element and stuff like that
it's like some of the stuff with the
actual family drama is not like heavy
but isn't super cheery it's pretty heavy
James Caan slaps around his wife white a
bit in this movie yeah every scene at
their home is just screaming and
domestic abuse and I think it's
important for kids to realize that
domestic violence will happen in your
home and stalking will get you a
girlfriend as evidenced by the Will
Ferrell Zooey Deschanel
exactly exactly and this also got peter
dinklage peter dinklage peter dinklage
peter dinklage peter dinklage peter
dinklage peter dinklage that's a
greatest song of all time to guys well
I'm excited to watch elf again this
December with my lady girlfriend woman
thingy she has this as one of her
favorite Christmas movies ever so eating
it I have to know Joe I'm not paying I
go watch this movie I don't care about
it that much yes man where are the
revival screenings of yes man every year
I'm gonna be watching this again soon
and I'm very much excited looking to it
hey listen I want to give a patient a
shot so a man named Mikhail Linden he's
a guy who I say is from Switzerland but
really he's from Sweden I just say that
to trigger him because I am Mormon
McHale we last spoke
at near the end of October you were
venting to me about how you were upset
that Luke Cage got canceled and Iron
Fist got canceled and I get it I know I
was bunked to I don't think they're
gonna do the Heroes for Hire thing and I
responded to you you know what I don't
like I don't like that you do the thing
to me that I do to way too many people
throughout the week yes send me a
message I send you a message there's
stuff to go off of and you don't message
me back that makes me upset that makes
me very upset stay pledged to our patron
page though please but know that I'm
very mad at you yeah and the only way
for me to forgive you is if your pledge
goes through till January when the ads
really dip on YouTube so you need to
fund us throughout the month of January
and all will be forgiven
that won't be cool yeah you are our
financier or you can save some money and
just reply back to my message yeah and
then we'll shut down for all of January
so it's your choice really what do you
want the choice is yours let the games
begin
that's what we should watch for
Christmas dude yeah saw saw saw seven
nine either one's good just one we got
to wait for guys I'm on movie fights I'm
gonna be just as energetic as I am now
subscribe to the real rejects click
Belles and check out screen junkies news
I actually watch them every day I just
steal their opinions and then say it on
movie fights and I pander to the judges
that's the way I roll
[Applause]